Уже місяць мешканці підмосковного Волоколамська
не можуть дихати на повні груди
- в повітрі періодично виникає різкий запах, від
якого, без перебільшення, голова йде обертом.
У мене запаморочення, нудота і болі в животі.
Я ще навіть носом не відчуваю, а організм вже дає
алергічну реакцію, тому що в роті виникає гіркота.
Через різкий запах у повітрі Юлія потрапила в лікарню.
Дівчина стала чи не єдиною в місті, в кого лікарі визнали факт отруєння.
Мені поставили діагноз, що це алергічна реакція на
газ від твердих побутових відходів, який я вдихнула.
У довідці це чітко написано.
Всім іншим, хто звертався після мене, заборонили писати цей діагноз.
Бо галас зробився.
Джерело ядучого запаху - сміттєзвалище "Ядрово".
Віднедавна, за вказівкою уряду Москви, саме суди
звозять сміття не тільки з найближчих сіл, а й зі столиці.
Крім того, чиновники вдвічі збільшили норму обсягів сміття.
Співробітників полігону роблять винними і крайніми в цій ситуації.
Кажуть, що тут не дотримуються технологій.
Наш полігон повністю відповідає проектним рішенням.
Ввезення та прийом відходів на полігон нині регулюється
територіальною схемою по роботі з відходами Московської області,
вважайте, це закон Московської області.
Згідно з ним, ми повинні приймати 420 тисяч тонн відходів рік.
- А зараз розраховане на 200? - Так.
Ситуація погіршилася 21 березня, коли через викид
газу на звалищі в центральну лікарню Волоколамска
звернулися понад 50 дітей - усі зі скаргами на отруєння.
Станом на 25 березня, викид газу на сміттєвому
полігоні перевищував норму в сім разів.
Громадськість вимагає закрити звалище.
Керівництво сміттєполігону каже - це неможливо.
На їхню думку, слід провести рекультивацію
полігону і на це вже витратили 120 мільйонів рублів.
Після тривалих переговорів активістам і місцевій
владі вдалося домовитися - фахівці з Нідерландів
через два тижні почнуть дегазацію сміттєзвалища.
Поки не закінчиться робота на старому тілі полігону,
на нове тіло полігону нічого завозити не будуть.
Це перший етап
Це перший етап, якого ми добилися.
Якщо влада не дає людям дихати, люди перекриють
кисень владі - кажуть протестувальники.
Після численних пікетів активістам вдалося дечого домогтися:
звільнили голову Волоколамського району та
тимчасово зупинили завозити сміття на "Ядрово".
Протестувальники кажуть, що вони готові й далі
відстоювати своє право на чисте довкілля.